- [Kelly] Thank you so much for being here
and supporting my show.
- I'm so excited for you, congratulations.
- Thank you. I told you at game night.
- You did not have to beg me.
I told you immediately that I would come.
- [Kelly] Well, you're kind of a big deal.
So, you're very lovely.
- [Jennifer] Oh, no.
- But our first time we ever
met, I have to tell y'all was
at Hollywood Game night.
And this was how I knew I loved
her cause she legit walked
up to me, we've never met-
- I think I know what you're
gonna say, I'm embarrassed.
- She walked up and got
this close and then she goes
"Kelly Clarkson, I did
not come here to lose."
She was so competitive.
- A little bit. It makes
me sweat thinking about it.
I haven't even watched it
- [Kelly] I tried and had to turn it off
- because it might give me
a heart palpitation. Yeah.
- Well, cause I'm annoying.
- [Jennifer}] I mean We did win.
- We did win, yes.
- There is no.
- Yep. Yeah I get annoyingly
competitive at games.
- [Jennifer] I do too. It's not that cute.
- Yeah no. Well we have a clip
of a few of our finer moments
- [Jennifer] (laughs) Oh my God.
- so watch this.
- [Kelly] Ready to play.
GO GO GO. Oh my God.
She was funny comedienne.
- M-M-Mary Tyler Moore.
- Yes!
She was a senator and it was
great. She was on The View.
- Oh. McCain. Meghan McCain.
- Yes!
- I know it was leopard
and not shepard. Come on.
Yes!
- Kelly Clarkson is just no joke.
- I mean, we might come
across a little crazy
but we won and we're awesome.
- Yeah. And you want us on
your team, basically, in life.
- Unless you want to lose, so yeah.
But I did, I had so much
fun that night with you.
I literally felt like
we were kindred spirits.
I'm a little more extra than you which,
I'm sorry it's a lot to handle.
- I don't know, yeah.
- I think I scared Jane Lynch.
Well, I'm gonna find her
and we're gonna make up.
But I thought we had so much
fun playing one of the games so
I thought I know we were on a
team together but it might be
fun if we play against each other, maybe.
- Really? Really?
- Maybe to see why Jen our team won.
Maybe to see who the weakest
link is, I don't know.
I don't know.
- What?
- [Kelly] But later in the
show we're gonna do that.
- Oh no no no. You know what, bring it.
- I love you.
- I know I'm like we're so
great together, it's on.
- Oh yeah.
- Do you play games with your kids? I do.
- Yes. Yeah for sure.
Have you ever played One
Night Ultimate Werewolf?
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- Have you all played it?
- No one has played that. No.
- It's so much fun. Yes.
One Night Ultimate Werewolf, super fun.
I don't really understand the point.
It's all about trying to catch
each other in a lie and my
kids are so good at it I feel
like why am I teaching them
this skill? But um.
- I would suck at that game. I'm bad.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- I have no filter.
- Clearly. No.
- Clearly.
- That one is really fun.
Code Names is really fun.
- [Kelly] Code Names.
- Code Names
- I love Code Names. It's good.
- Yeah it's good.
- I get very competitive at
rules which Jane thought I
cheated on Hollywood Game Night.
Did not know I was cheating,
I thought we were allowed to
tell each other.
- Well, thank God you told
me. We wouldn't have won.
- We killed everyone.
- If you don't know the
rules, it's not cheating.
- Exactly, I didn't know.
I think she thinks I cheated, whatever.
- Whatever, we'll make up.
- We will. I'm gonna find her.
I'm gonna hunt her down like
I'm hunting Meryl. But where
in the world, on this planet,
do you have time to
like garden, cook, prep,
do all this stuff?
Like you're so into gardening, I am too.
But I don't have a ton of time.
Like how do you find the time
and do your kids eat your food?
- Well, the harder you work on a meal
the less likely they are to eat it.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- Have you ever noticed that?
When you really sweat and
you've really tried something
new that's when they're just
like "I'm not hungry, thanks."
Which is code for I don't like it.
But "I'm not really hungry,
I'm okay. I had apples."
And you just feel like argh.
But if you throw something
together then, you know.
- That's literally every parent you just
described at meal time.
Especially my three year old son
I'm like seriously? It
doesn't matter what I put.
I could put apples in front
of him and he loves it
then the next day he's
like "I hate apples."
- Right, right right. The
trick is to care less.
Don't wear caring on your face.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- And don't try.
- [Kelly] Nonchalant.
- Yeah.
- You're just pfft, I don't
care if you don't eat it.
- Whatever, I made
homemade pasta it's fine.
- [Kelly] It took me
three hours, it's fine.
- Yeah. It's like eat
it or not, it's fine.
It doesn't even matter. Take it to Kelly.
- [Kelly] I carried you for
nine months, but suck it. Sure.
Yeah, yeah. Everything's fine.
- So yes, they do sometimes.
Now that they're getting older
they're starting to eat more.
- Yeah. So where did Once
Upon a Farm come from?
Because we actually have
it in our household,
that's no lie they actually love it.
- [Jennifer] I'm so glad.
When my kids were babies,
I went to the store, I was a working mom.
The first thing that I opened,
it looks like cat food.
Baby food in a grocery store.
It's been sitting on a shelf forever
and a can shouldn't sit
there longer than a Twinkie.
Everything's been cooked out of it,
it just doesn't even make sense.
So I knew there had to be a new
and a better and a different way,
and I found Cassandra Curtis and Ari Ross
and they were doing this
amazing, different way of making
baby food just using technology
and cold pressing it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that you don't cook
the nutrients out of it.
It has all the fiber and
the flavor and the colors
and the vibrancy and the vitamins.
- That's what cold pressing is,
a lot of people don't know what that is.
- [Jennifer] Yes.
- It keeps all of that still in there.
- Yes. So what it does is you
put it under the pressure of
like nine oceans basically.
The weight of nine
oceans is what they say.
- So my ass. Anywho, um.
But you were raised on a farm, right?
- I wasn't raised on a farm,
my mom was raised on a farm.
- [Kelly] Oh, in Oklahoma.
That's right, that's right.
- In Oklahoma. Now it's our family farm
and now it's growing produce
for Once Upon a Farm.
- That is so great, dude.
- [Jennifer] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Congratulations.
- It's so much fun.
- [Kelly] I know and
especially when you're a parent
it's like you don't care about
yourself but for some reason
when you start procreating you're like
"wait, what's going in them?"
- Well, you know what's
funny is you talk to friends
and they say "my dog is
eating human grade food,
I mean you could eat the
food that my dog eats.
It's in a cooler at the grocery store."
And then meanwhile we go and
buy baby food and it's mush
and that's what we're used
to. It doesn't make sense.
- [Kelly] It's like food with no color.
That's like the worst for them,
when it's all just like beige.
- Right, right right right.
They're like "no green"
and I'm like "okay cool"
and then I hide it in a sippy cup.
- So it's great.
We offer all the recipes
for anything that we do.
We always have a great hero
ingredient like tumeric
because that's cool.
- [Kelly] Yes. It really
is, it's anti-inflammatory.
- Or chia seeds or flax or
all kinds of different things.
We always have something
great in there for
brain development or whatever
and so we offer the recipes.
If you can make it, great. If you can't,
we've got you covered.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I do. I think it's so important.
My husband and I since we moved out here,
our farm is in Tennessee
it's a little rough commute.
So we're selling that
and we bought a ranch
in Montana because of you.
You were talking about Montana.
We were planning on Colorado
but we bought this ranch
and we're doing all the self sustain.
- Good. I am so excited.
- I love people like you, you inspire us
to stand up and do that.
And you're hilarious
because I follow you online.
You talk to your chickens
and you sing to your bees.
You do all this crazy
stuff that's awesome.
- Well I mean what're you gonna do?
You have to laugh at yourself.
- But no, you name your chickens.
- [Jennifer] Yes.
- [Kelly] What are maybe a
couple names of your chickens?
- [Jennifer] That was Captain Hook.
- [Kelly] Oh, hi chickens. Captain Hook.
- Oprah Henfrey's next. We have Hennifer.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And then we're gonna do
Ellen Deheneres. Oprah Henfrey.
- I'm just throwing it out there,
but Kelly Cluckson is
cool too. I'm just saying.
- What.
- We have chickens too.
I will name one of mine Hennifer,
if you name mine Kelly Cluckson.
- I will for sure have Kelly
Cluckson. That is for sure.
Do you have a preference? Do
you want to be an olive egger,
do you want to be?
- I want to be the craziest
chicken in the coop.
- Done. Confirmed. Oh no.
- Because I feel like that would be.